[Musik]
das ist die geschichte von bertrich
trainer die es wagte aus liebe zur
windhunden ihre gut bezahlte manager
stelle in der schweiz aufzugeben um
ausgerechnet auf hunde rennbahnen in
irland ihr glück zu suchen
[Musik]
ja windhundrennen haben in irland
tradition seit bald 100 jahren lassen
die iren ihre hunde auf rennbahnen
gegeneinander antreten
niemand hat darauf gewartet dass seine
frau und noch dazu eine ausländerin
damit mischt doch seit sieben jahren tut
bertrich steiner genau das auf ihrem hof
bei canon unweit der nordirischen grenze
lebt sie mit 80 windhunden eigenen und
solchen die sie für kunden züchtet
aufzieht schult und trainiert das kommt
bei den alteingesessenen ihren nicht
immer gut an
dank uns ja schon einige probiert und
also spitze sich keine zählung bleiben
die meisten ja wieder luft gehört
einfach will
ich hoffe kompletten andere kultur
darunter große bevölkerungsgruppe wo
graham trainer macht und dass sie sind
sie reif sind das aus freunden
untereinander also ist wirklich schwere
jene trow es dort mit einheimischen
beschäftigt sich die 48 jährige lieber
mit ihren hunden einer ihrer großen
hoffnungsträger ist swiss jet er gehört
einer gruppe von schweizern dem team
swiss syndikat und hat einen marktwert
von 4000 franken
diesen wird swiss jet in wenigen tagen
am größten rennen des landes verteidigen
müssen
für steiner nicht nur eine frage von
gewinnen oder verlieren sondern auch
eine herzensangelegenheit und start
bringen und parade nicht und da wird
jeder hund speziell vorstellt und den
besitzer teams wissen die kraft
denn ich mir natürlich schon stolz dass
irgendwer gern bin durch und durch und
durch schwizer und daniel land warnt
werner und mit ihnen ihr land wirklich
war im land und tritt also dass ich
schlussendlich irgendwo dodenau
marktanteilen in island lage nicht und
weil man ein wort genau wird das
schweizer
das ist ein gewisses wissen
für steiner stand die wahl ihres
auswanderungs landes außer frage
aus irland kommen die schnellsten
windhunde der beste ort für sie ihre
ambitionen in erfolg zu verwandeln
nathalie abi ist die lebenspartnerin von
beate steiner
gemeinsam führen sie den hof die 38
jährige fotografin aus darmstadt hatte
sie schon als jugendliche in windhunde
verliebt die zwei frauen könnten sich
gerade mal drei monate
als sie hierher in die fremde zogen dazu
gar nicht essen ich stehen sorgt die
puten dir das mal an wobei die einen
daran ist erneut der salomon
ja ja ja also wenn du willst dass die
geflüchtet haben
ich züchte sie ich setze sie in die welt
ich bin von der ersten lebens minute mit
diesem kleinen und ab einem bestimmten
punkt übergebe ich sie ihr ganz bewusst
und für die art und weise die sie dann
mit diesen geschöpfen umgeht ist da
wächst meine liebe immer immer mehr und
mein respekt immer immer mehr weil es
einfach so wahnsinnig viel sinn macht
und weil es einfach so wahnsinnig schön
erstaunlicherweise sorgte die beziehung
zwischen den beiden frauen im
erzkatholisch konservativen irland kaum
für reaktionen
für die leute hier sei die schlicht kein
thema sagen sie wieder noch eine
ausländische frau die ihren platz in
einer männerdominierten welt reklamiert
das verursachte hingegen durchaus gerede
mehr noch gewisse trainer sorgten
patrick steiner direkt ins gesicht was
sie davon halten
das theoretische wissen ja wir haben
schon unsere herausforderung hier also
ich glaube richtig respekt und
angekommen dass zuerst bin so eins
dieser einstigen von augen in den augen
der iren für uns ist alles gut wir sind
happy sowieso aber hier geht es nur ums
gewinnen also zweiter oder dritter
wenn du darüber wird gar nicht
gesprochen
du musst siegen und dass es eigentlich
nicht ganz so das was wir im auge haben
um siegen ging es schon in steiners
früheren leben bevor die maschinenbau
und betriebswirtschaft ingenieurwesen
und 40 ihren aussteiger traum
verwirklichte arbeitete sie jahrelang im
kader verschiedener
medizinaltechnikunternehmen auch damals
zählte nur top leistungen
für nächsten titel wie sah der alltag
vasile schweikardt und hosen als bin
dann schon aber es ist gott jetzt bin
ich für unverantwortlich und dran das so
machen wenn ich es richtig halte und was
besser studios machen und dass manager
durch sollte länger wie schwieriger will
man sich nicht nur fit tour ständig
sondern muss management glücklich machen
und das ist heute nacht freunde hat sind
wir nicht immer steht die gurgel
und da ich mir das eigentlich egal
solange sie kriegen und dann eine hündin
[Musik]
für die managerin gab es nur einen weg
zum glück weg von großkonzernen hin zu
einem ehrlichen und bodenständigen leben
in einer umgebung die der 100 trainerin
schon immer mehr behagt als die teppich
etage
ich reiße nicht der woche in die schweiz
meine mutter hat geburtstag
schön ist das wetter
wir waren zu weit für uns es sind die
trainer aufträge mit denen sie steiner
einen namen macht das geld bringen aber
zucht und schulung der hunde in den
ersten jahren floss deshalb viel
erspartes in den großen traum
seit einem jahr trägt sich der hof nun
selbst viel geld für luxus bleibt
trotzdem nicht
ist das reduzierte lebe für sie in
gewinne teilweise auch den verlust
also das ist für mich also eine momentan
plant ich denke nicht dass es genauso
für für immer sie wird und darum ist für
mich und grün will ich dann so dankl so
dass ein ganz einfachen aber das würde
ich sehr wahrscheinlich nie mehr das man
dass man noch mit kohle oder holz zu
heizen
was man fürs warmwasser zerstört dass
die schulträger muss antworten muss
besucht
aber jeder schritt planen muss
hunde freie momente sind für die frauen
überaus selten noch denn irgendwann soll
auch wieder mehr zeit für die
partnerschaft bleiben und zwar abseits
von hundegebell feld wiese rennbahn und
manchmal sogar das drehkreuz steiner
musste erfinderisch werden um alle ihre
hunde auf trab zu halten
mit verschiedenen trainingsmethoden und
frischem futter das mit vitaminen fetten
und ölen ergänzt wird bringt sie ihre
hunde zu bestleistungen woraus letztlich
gehört aber auch bei tieren ein talent
für den rennsport dazu ein angeborenes
gewinner gehen die pflege der tiere
setzt wissen voraus steiner hat es sich
durch ihre ausbildung zur orthopädie
steen und spezialisierte seminare
angeeignet es sind aber vor allem die 25
jahre erfahrung dank denen sie jede art
typische bewegung des hundes und jedes
schräge bällen sofort deuten kann
sondern da behandle mit rasant er hat
sich wieder wissens der fußspitze
verknackst verletzung aber tue mich aber
das schaffe mir ja ja
das sind recht klein jahre schließlich
sollen große offene oder drinnen
sie sind ähnlich hatte sich laufend 20
stunden und die vier stunden wach sind
daran zerbrechen aber da waren wirklich
machen da man selbst aber da muss etwas
passieren
[Musik]
steiner ist überzeugt entspannen können
die hunde am besten mit schweizer radio
im hintergrund
[Musik]
die
kommerzielle windhundrennen sind
weltweit nur noch in acht ländern
erlaubt
eine szene die in irland immer häufiger
anzutreffen ist sind aufgebrachte
gruppen von tierschützern die
windhundrennen aufs schärfste
verurteilen
und als schande brandmarken angeprangert
werden überzüchtung tierquälerei und die
grausame ermordung jener hunde die ihre
leistung nicht oder nicht mehr erbringen
[Applaus]
ich will das windhundrennen in irland
verboten werden komplett 100 prozent es
ist falsch
diese industrie basiert auf einem modell
von überzüchtung man züchter zu viele
windhunde weil die besten aus und
entsorgt die anderen
sie nennen sie abfall wir holen
windhunde wieder zurück aus china und
bangladesch in dieser länder werden sie
nach dem ende ihrer rennkarriere
exportiert und zur zucht genutzt bis sie
fast tot sind
manche enden so war im fleischhandel
[Musik]
steiner spürt gegenwind nicht bloß
seitens der männerdominierten branche
sie muss auch gegen den schlechten ruf
ankämpfen den der hundesport hat der
besucher sich erfreut darüber dass
bezirk krems strand des regens gegen wen
er wofür umbruch werde der antrag
überhaupt
der hund rannte wie das hat er im
adrenalin das bemühen denn zufolge gibt
es nicht jeder hund ist sich und wir
zeigen eine grüne hat sich freut wenn
die hunde älterwerden ihre wilden jahre
vorbei sind suchen steine und partnerin
natalie ihnen einen platz als haustier
für sie die hunde lieben ist es
selbstverständlich dafür zu sorgen dass
es den hunden in einem neuen daheim gut
geht und so vermitteln sie plätze nicht
nur für ihre eigenen sondern auch für
hunde anderer trainer macht und wenn man
sich das nicht rechtfertigen oder mutig
wird hat das ja auch durch einen sinn
also man muss versuchen das auf ortslage
was die gute sitten ist und vielleicht
heute genau türen öffnen und zeigen wir
haben das machen wir alles so dass für
seinen schlag wird kleine fluss mekong
beatrice steiner ist unerschrocken wenn
es darum geht missstände in der eigenen
branche anzuprangern
und sie zeigt schwarze schafe ohne
zögern beim nationalen verband für
wintersport an
[Musik]
beim wegzug in die fremde ist es ein
bisschen wie auf dem rennplatz gewinn
und niederlage liegen manchmal
bedrohlich nah beieinander
doch die liebe zu den tieren war das
risiko wert auch wenn steiner viel dafür
aufgeben musste ich habe sehr viel
zurück ich habe familie zurück ich habe
freunde zurücklassen ortsrand klar wann
ich mich wohl gefühlt habe und ich mich
drinnen bewegt haben und nicht wissen
wie er sich zu verhalten
es ist meine heimat wenig zu hören
ich bin aus einfach bitter ist der herr
hoffmann hat mit über mich grüßt das hat
kaum jemand interessiert ich habe mich
zuerst müssen bestätigen
mittlerweile ist ganz klar wird dass
gray und trainer
sie gehört zu den schelm park trainer
kurz unter die ersten 25 trainer nimmt
mich doch auch ernst also verfolgt wie
hoeneß markt was resultate gemacht hat
man gratuliert mir
man nimmt mich auf jeden fall war die
umgebung mag sich zwar grundlegend
verändert haben
steiner jedoch nicht sie lebt noch immer
für ihren beruf
statt zahlen besessener konzernbosse
diktieren nun allerdings die hunde ihren
alltag egal ob beim spaziergang beim
kochen rennen oder fernsehschauen seit
bald 30 jahren sieht man steiner kam je
ohne wind und an ihrer seite
aber er gibt mir wahnsinnig viel
ich möchte dass möglichst im naturell
sich entwickelt und dann schlussendlich
oder von zeigen was in ihm steckt
finaltag das große rennen in melbourne
park dublin den wichtigsten rennt platz
des landes wer hier gewinnt ist jemand
dreieinhalb jahre aufzucht dutzende
stunden training hat sich die harte
arbeit gelohnt wird es hier swiss jet
aufs siegertreppchen schaffen
die klatsche
zu sagen
wer bezahlt
[Musik]
heute geht es um ruhm und ehre ein
preisgeld von 2500 franken
vor allem aber um die frage ob auch eine
frau und ausländerin einen windhund zum
champion trainieren kann
[Musik]
besser
so tragen wir nicht mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und er hätte
für die position
[Applaus]
es ist schade das ist mutig aber er hat
hat sich wenig einsätze richtig
positionieren
dort wird wenig zu schwingen wollen und
jetzt ein zweiter nur wenige
millisekunden am sieg vorbei 450 franken
preisgeld
eine solide leistung die steine und die
schweizer besitzer von swiss jet stolz
machen hält mir keine besser sie der
konkurrenz weiter super gut gestartet
gesund freut als genial kroymans
hintertür zum dem volk und strand
excellence spiegelt wieder verschlossen
wie der hund also vor der ganzen
aufregung vor dem adrenalin krieg und
glück das ist für beate steiner immer
wieder ein schneller und dabei muss ja
gar nicht der schnellste im rennen sein
[Musik]
dazu